was the time period for the
observing uh of a fast and abstaining
from the things which break the fast
which you've already
mentioned always the same since the
beginning of time or for the
Muslims as far as the Muslims are
concerned when the first time it was
mentioned in the Quran in Sur Bak
chapter was 183 which I mentioned
earlier that fasting was F at that time
the Muslims used to fast 3 days in a
month later on when the verse of the
Quran was revealed of Surah Bak chapter
number 2 verse number 18 185 which I
quoted the second time that Raman is the
month in which the Quran was
revealed and in it is guidance for the
humankind and in it assigns for guidance
and judgment right and wrong so the
Muslim then they witness this month they
should fast so then it became f for the
Muslim to fast the complete month of
Ramadan first it was only 3 days every
month then it became one full month only
the month of Ramadan as far as the
things that break the faster concern one
of the things that break the fast it is
sexual intercourse even with your
wife so previously when this verse of
Surah Bak CH 2 verse number 185 was
revealed it was not mentioned in detail
so the Muslim at that time they used to
abstain from sexual intercourse
approaching their wife for the full
month of Ramadan even during the day and
night and it was very difficult for many
of the Muslims many of the sahabas and
that reminds me of a quotation or
incidence which is mentioned in one of
the commentaries of the Quran you read
the commentary of the Quran volume
number two page number
210 it mentions there that omab may
Allah be pleased with
him once after speaking with the prophet
late in the night he comes back home and
he has the urge to sleep with his wife
and he spends the time with his wife and
he has sexual intercourse with his wife
in the morning when he gets up he feels
very bad he's ashamed he immediately
goes to the prophet and he says that I
ask pardon from Allah and his for what
I've have done and my soul was attracted
towards my wife and I had a relationship
with my wife in the night is there any
way that I can be pardoned or is there
any way that I can
escape so the prophet said Is it true
that you actually did this he said yes
Prophet Prophet was shocked how could
Omar may Allah be pleased with him could
do a thing at that time it was
prohibited he said yes Allah messenger I
did it is anyway I can be pardoned so
the prophet said no one beses Allah can
give the command and alhamdulillah
alhamdulillah immediately after this the
verse of Surah Bak chapter number two
verse number 187 was revealed it says
that permitted to
you during the nights of the fast is
approaching your
wives and then it say
that they are your garments and you are
the garments that means your wives are
your garments and you are the garments
of your wife and Allah says that we know
what you do secretly in the night but
Allah forgive you and from now onwards
you can approach your wives during the
nights of The Fast and you can eat and
drink till the white thread of dawn is
differentiated from the black thread so
when this verse was revealed later on
Sur Bak 2 verse number 87 then the rules
were bit more relaxed that they could
have sexual relationship with their wife
during the nights but during the day
they have to abstain furthermore as far
as eating was concerned previously
before Sur Bak CH 2 verse number 187 was
revealed the Muslims could eat and drink
after the sunsets but the moment they
sleep after that they can't eat then
they can eat only the next day after
sunsets so there the incident one of the
sahabas pleas with him he worked very
hard and he was
fasting and it was time to break the
fast he comes home and he tells his wife
that I want to have some food so wife
says that there's no food in the house I
just get it from outside and she goes
out to get food now because he was tired
working the full day by the time the
wife comes back he goes to sleep when
the wife comes back to the house she
sees the husband has gone to sleep so
now she says finish once he's gone to
sleep he can't eat so that night he
could not eat the next day he had to
fast and by evening the next day he
faints and the people go to the prophet
that this is what happened because once
you sleep you can't eat later on this
verse for which I said earlier Surah Bak
chap 2 vers number 97 which says besides
approaching your wives at night you can
eat and drink till the white thread of
dawn is differentiated from the black
thread so then the rules that we follow
today that fasting means that they have
to abstain from food and drink and
nourishment as well as from sexual
intercourse right from dawn un
Sunset and having the intention that we
have to bre Allah subh tala it's an act
of worship so this is the history how we
finally got this